what's the story about you entering a
singing competition we'll see first of
all I started out singing in contests so
me and my sister who still my assistance
in today as kids we will go and like
when all the talent shows and we will
split the money and he would get 10% so
not too long ago we have to try hand at
it again and we were and we were in
Florida and we went to like random
bowling alley and they so happen to have
like a karaoke contest and I was like oh
I'm sent into this contest and he's won
and it was so excited but like they
didn't know I was Jennifer husband it's
like you just won $75 I was like oh it's
everybody come back next week it'll be
even more money I was like I will be
back
you